I am one of those people I checked my
phone hundreds of times a day sometimes
just for a second to see if I have any
important messages or to get the time
sure I could do this but it's a little
problematic instead there's the promise
of the smart watch a watch that delivers
all the most important information right
to your wrist and Google's Android wear
promises to be the first viable platform
to do just that next week's the first
two android wear smartwatches ship the
LG G watch for two hundred and twenty
nine dollars and the galaxy gear live
for a hundred and ninety nine dollars
the problem is is that both of these
acts a lot like this they look like
shrunken smartphones and sometimes they
act like them to get the Android wear
phone app pair the watch via bluetooth
with a newer Android phone and things
start ticking swipe up the 1.6 inch
screen and cards appear with your phone
notifications how many steps you've
taken today and Android wears real
secret weapon information from Google
now Google now the search engine system
for prompting you with information you
need before you even know you need it is
a perfect fit on a wrist for instance if
Google now knows when and where my next
appointment is it just buzz my wrist and
told me I should leave now based on
traffic don't tell me what to do but
don't worry you can also tell the watch
what to do
ok Google remind me not to talk on my
watch when I'm crossing the street
boys commands work extremely well
letting you do everything from set an
alarm to search the web to send a
message
okay Google text Wilson Rothman my watch
is a much better listener than you
Android apps are starting to work with
the watches - some are useful the Delta
app put my ticket right on my wrist at
boarding time this has been my wrist for
the last week okay maybe that's a slight
exaggeration but every time I get a
notification on my phone I get it on my
wrist and I don't want the same
notifications in both places I do want
to be notified every time my editor or
fiance contacts me I don't want to be
notified every time I get an Instagram
like you can mute notifications from
individual apps but Google says it hopes
to give users more specific controls by
contacts soon in addition both watches
had performance glitches and had to be
charged every day with proprietary
charging cradles and unlike fitness
bands these watches can't do much beyond
counting steps and good luck seeing the
screen in the Sun
and they're certainly not stylish or
slim they look more like cheap sports
watches this is what happened when I
tried to wear it to my best friend's
wedding
if you in a cell phone on your arm you
cannot be in my wedding but even if you
think either of these smartwatches look
smart buy one right now would be stupid
we reported that Apple is working on an
iWatch and more stylish Android wear
watches and improve software are coming
soon
which means for now stuck with this